MATT MCNULTY: All right.
I'm Matt McNulty.
I lead the Polymer
team here at Google.
That's a little small.
I blame Eric, he actually made
these slides-- not the slides,
but the framework for them.
So my Twitter handle is there.
Feel free to tweet
at me any time.
About every three
months or so, I
start getting tweets from
mostly women in the UK
saying that they love me
because apparently there's
an actor there whose name
is also Matt McNulty,
and they follow me instead.
So feel free to tweet
at me because I think
my most recent 10 tweets or so
are all about that because I
have to repeatedly point
out that I'm not an actor.
But yeah, so,
apparently, he's been
in something that's
not so great right now.
But there's still a few people
that love him, apparently.
So it's a nice
little ego stroke.
So first thing I
wanted to show you,
we have this designer tool.
And we showed the beginnings
of it at I/O last year.
And it's evolved quite
a bit since then.
It's actually all
new code since then.
And a few people are going
to be showing it tonight.
So I just wanted to
introduce it really quickly.
So this is what Steve
Jobs would call a hobby.
This is not actually our
thing we're working on.
But it's particularly useful
for showing off components.
Eric talked about it
for a little while,
just about how composable
these things are,
and how interop works, and
how it's really, really
awesome that you can
do things like drag
out a whole scaffold that's
built into an element.
And I can maximize it.
And if I flip to the code view,
which is very, very small as
well, you see that
all that is really
just a little bit of markup.
So it's really pretty cool.
And Rob's going to demo this a
whole lot more in a little bit
as is Salesforce, so it'll
be pretty cool for you.
But I just kind of
wanted to show that
and just show how
powerful Polymer is,
and how you can build a lot with
just a little bit of markup.
So how did I do that?
Polymer.
That's our pretty new logo
that you all now have toys of,
which is pretty
awesome, by the way.
We all spent about
four hours trying
to make them look like the logo.
And that's actually
pretty challenging
if you don't have
something to work on.
But so the big question
is what is Polymer?
So Polymer is a library
utilizing web components,
which you just learned,
about for building elements
and applications.
So that's a lot of words.
None of them have
a lot of meaning
other than web
components at this point?
Web components, elements,
applications, like everyone
talks about that.
These are very generic words.
So really, what is Polymer?
So Polymer is actually
a new kind of thing.
This is something that
we need to do a better
job of explaining to people.
So this is not like the
things that have come before.
Web components shipping is
a major inflection point,
kind of, in the history
of web development.
So there's going to be kind
of the things that came before
and the things that came after.
And way you build
the web applications
is going to change, regardless
of whether you use Polymer
or not.
This is the future
of web development.
And it's the future
we were always
promised, way back in the day.
This is the hoverboard.
This is the thing
that we were told,
you can build
applications this way.
This is the way
it's going to be.
But it's actually here now.
And the only thing out there
that's this in any way similar
is actually X-Tags,
which Daniel Buchner's
going to come talk
about in a little bit.
Basically, everything
else is-- we're still
out in front right
now and just trying
to figure this
whole situation out.
And these things haven't
even shipped completely
in the browser yet.
So we're kind of out in Front
So Polymer uses web components.
Eric talked about web
components quite a bit.
But the major
differentiator with Polymer
and things that came
before is Polymer
doesn't paper over the platform.
So as everyone in this room
is probably painfully aware,
frameworks have had to
deal with a deficient web
platform for a
couple decades now.
It just doesn't provide
enough functionality out
of the box to be
useful for people.
And web components
and object observe,
and a template tag change that
because a platform doesn't
need to be papered over anymore.
So we came to Google
to prove this.
So A, to prove that
the specs were good,
and we did a lot
of work on that,
and also to prove
that they're useful,
that you can build
something new out of this
and that these things are
useful right out of the box.
So wait, Polymer
isn't a framework?
They keep calling it a library.
I'm saying previous
frameworks, things like that's.
It's a little confusing.
So with Polymer, the
thing we like to say,
is the framework is DOM.
So instead of
building a framework
on top of the web platform,
now, if the web platform
is extensible, now that it
has scoping via shadow DOM,
you can actually build things
and just use DOM methods again.
So when we built
Enyo, the fastest way
to render something
on the page was
to splat out a big long
string in innerHTML.
And we came to Google and
joined the Chrome scene.
And we were like, well,
this is the fastest way.
And they're like, no it's not.
And we went and looked,
and it wasn't anymore.
They had actually made creating
DOM nodes imperatively faster.
So our mission here is
to use the platform,
and the platform is DOM.
And DOM is much more functional
now than it used to be.
And our component model
was custom elements.
We don't need a component
model built out of JavaScript
because custom
elements now provide
that same functionality
in the platform.
And scoping, again, is
provided by shadow DOM.
So a lot of people think
that shadow DOM provides
a level of security, or
that the JavaScript in it
runs in a different context.
And none of that's
actually true.
That would be useful
for some cases.
But what this
really does is kind
of the equivalent of classes
in almost any other language.
It's scoping that you can pierce
the boundaries of if you really
need to.
And it's still really,
really useful as is,
even though this isn't
quite what people think
might think it is by
the name shadow DOM.
So am I hating on
other frameworks?
We actually wrote
quite a few of them.
So there's people on the
team that helped write Dojo.
We all wrote Enyo.
And now we're here doing this.
But there's a ton of great JS
frameworks out there right now.
And they all had to do
superhuman things in order
to deal with the web platform
the way it exists right now.
They didn't work
on the Chrome team.
They didn't have Web Components.
They didn't have
any of that stuff.
And in my opinion,
actually, too much talent
is being spent
working on frameworks,
papering over deficiencies
in the platform.
And it's time to change that.
It's time to give those
people the ability
to build stuff beyond frameworks
that's actually interoperable.
So a brief word about Polyfills.
So Eric touched on this briefly.
The Polyfills are
kind of a bridge
to the future that's
available right now.
Polyfills are also a
lot of work to create.
So we built those Polyfills
for web components
and put them out there.
About a year ago at I/O,
when we unveiled Polymer
with its current
name and everything,
we've been open source
from the beginning,
the Polyfills
represented about 80%
of the work we'd actually
done to that point.
So we presented it
as all as Polymer
because this was new
enough for everyone else.
It turns out, like,
Polyfills are really--
they are something that is
supposed to go away over time.
And it's kind of
utilitarian thing.
And they're not
actually Polymer.
They're not what
we're providing.
Polymer is the layer
above the Polyfills.
So you'll see-- I see it
all the time where people
are like, oh, Polymer,
this set a Polyfills.
And it's actually not true.
The Polyfills are
a means to an end
they are a bridge to
the future platform.
And the other thing
about Polyfills
is that they actually
focus on compatibility
over everything else.
Their goal is not performance.
If you can make really
highly performant Polyfill,
you wouldn't need
the native features.
So a lot of times, you
have questions about that,
and it's like, you know what?
The idea is the Polymer
works everywhere
because of the Polyfills,
but it's awesome on Chrome
because it has it native.
So let's dig into Polymer.
So Polymer is a sugaring
layer on top of the Polyfills
that lets you build your
own elements sets and apps.
Again, sometimes you
hear people say, oh,
that's just for
building elements.
But it's actually for building
everything if you want.
Your element can
be an input tag.
be an entire app.
Eric did a great job of
showing a bunch of examples
of all that.
And Web Components, why did
we have to build Polymer?
Well, Web Components
are completely awesome.
But by design, they are a
really low level primitive.
It's in the name primitive.
And that's the way
primitives should be.
They should be maximally
flexible, maximally powerful,
and maybe not
necessarily as focused
on developer ergonomics.
So using them together right now
on their own is kind of tricky.
There's a lot of boilerplate.
There's a lot of ways that
you can go wrong really,
really quickly.
And Polymer's whole job is
to make this way easier.
So the other thing is
Polymer is opinionated.
So the things that are in the
lower levels in the platform
layer are standards track.
But Polymer is where
the opinion lies.
And we actually did some
changes here recently
where a lot of the
data binding stuff
we have was down in
the platform layer.
And it's really not actually
ready for standards track yet.
So we pulled it up into Polymer.
It makes Polymer
a little bigger,
but it really
streamlines our story
and makes it really clear that
that platform layer is intended
to go away and go
away fairly soon.
And the other
thing about Polymer
is these are conventions.
These aren't standards, right?
These have not gone through
the standards process.
And as such, they represent
our opinion, right?
So what is that opinion?
What's our philosophy?
So components all the way down.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank, you sir.
So we like to build things
out of smaller pieces
and compose them together.
And honestly, we
feel like that's
one of the major keys to
building a really big scalable
application.
So a lot of people believe
that strong typing is a key.
And it definitely is.
And one of the things
that we believe
is the separation of concerns.
If you've got a
developer, and he
can worry about just the thing,
the small composable pieces
that's in front of him that has
one job to do that's reusable,
you can compose that into
bigger and bigger pieces, right?
Smaller, reusable
components that
compose into larger components.
Those components compose
into applications.
And you can put those
applications wherever you want.
And scoping enables
this composition.
And again, it's scoping.
And shadow DOM is about
scoping, not security.
Not that I'm trying
to nail that home.
So the other piece of Polymer is
that everything is an element.
So this is our
implementation of components.
Custom elements are the
components of Polymer.
We use them
absolutely everywhere.
Eric touched on this.
We've got UI elements.
We also have, you
can wrap an API.
We have a core local storage.
And local storage is a
notoriously tricky API
to deal with.
And you can throw a core
local storage element
on your page, link to using data
binding from any data source,
and it persists.
And it's that simple.
It's really like a
couple mustache elements,
and you're set.
And even data, right?
We started out like JSON is
the format data should be in.
And we decided to really push
the envelope here and go, well,
what if we actually
stored data in markup?
I mean, it's basically JSON
and markup are essentially
the same thing with
a different syntax.
So some of this we're probably
pushing a little too far,
and we have to
really figure it out.
But we're trying to
really explore this.
Everything is an element.
Every single thing on your
page is a composable piece
you construct other things with.
And then finally, the last
major philosophical piece
is less code.
So don't repeat yourself is
a really big deal for us.
And we want developers
to only write
code that's unique to their
app, or unique to their element,
and nothing else.
And arguably, we're pretty
successful with that.
And you can always get better.
And the data binding,
including data binding,
which we haven't done
before, greatly reduces code.
And it's generally just
are a really awesome thing.
I think Rob's demo
is really going
to show that off
really strongly.
All right, so what's this world?
I've been talking
about what Polymer
is, what it isn't, and all
these different layers-- we
have a nice fancy
slide for that.
So native, the bottle
layer is the browser today.
And in reality, this is a
super, super rough surface
with a lot of nooks and crannies
where demons and dragons hide.
And it's really pretty awful.
And idea of the platform
layer of platforms JS
is it's a set a Polyfills
that lets everyone
build to the same
standards and puts them
across browsers today.
And the idea is this big purple
box goes away completely.
Polymer is this middle layer.
So Polymer is a layer
of sugar on top.
And it gives you an
easy way to build
these composable elements.
But this is our opinion--
this will never go away.
This is the thing, the
value we are providing.
And then what you build
with it is elements.
So from sets of elements,
to individual elements,
and we're working on this
kind of actively right now.
So when we think about
how to use Polymer,
there's really kind
of two major ways.
Using elements is the first one.
So we think that, the vast
majority of the world,
they just want a particular
element on their page.
If they've got a button
that's particularly cool,
it has some progress
indicator, and they
want to put it on their
website and not think about it.
And that's going to be the vast
majority of this kind of usage.
Most people build selects.
They don't re-created
them from scratch.
So this is the majority case.
But the majority case in this
room, and for developers,
is going to be
creating elements.
So we'll go over both of those.
So using elements, we have a
whole bunch of elements today.
We've namespaced most
of them core dash.
We did a clean up
a couple of weeks
ago where we put all the
stuff that we weren't really
concentrating on into the
Polymer labs organization
and left everything in Polymer.
And we originally
had Polymer dash
on every single element
and pretty much everyone
who built Polymer
elements just kept
calling their
things Polymer dash.
We realized that we needed
to set a good example.
So the core dash is
just a name space
that we're using for
core utility things that
can be reused in a lot
of different places.
But it's just a convention.
And, as Eric touched
on as well, we
have a whole bunch of
non visual elements
that we've built
in Polymer as well.
I've talked about core
local storage before.
And we have a whole
bunch of others.
And you can still see some
Polymer dash stuff there
that we haven't
quite updated yet.
I focused on this being an
accurate slide as opposed
to particularly sensical.
And Polymer actually already
has well over 100 elements
at this point.
You can actually check
them out at Polymer Repo
and then also the Polymer
labs organization.
So to use an element,
again, this is just
kind of for everyone, the
first step is to get the code.
We tend to use
bower on the team.
But you can also use, we
have zips for everything,
you can use github,
you can use whatever
you want to use to get the code.
So if you bower an
element and then include
platform.js at the
top of your page,
and this is what gives
you the platform,
the Polyfills will fall
back to the native code
automatically as it goes.
And then you import the element.
This is an HTML import
that Eric showed you.
You link rel and then
name of the element,
and it's a .html
file, for first time.
You're not importing JavaScript.
You're importing HTML.
And then once you do
that, you can just
use the element anywhere on
your page, and it just works.
So it's really that
simple to get going.
But now creating elements is
where it gets interesting.
And this gets to where Polymer
provides a lot of value.
So we created a Polymer
dash element-- and this
is kind of the base
class of Polymer--
that you used to
define your elements.
So this one, in
particular, just has,
it's really, really simple.
It actually has noscript
attribute in there.
It's just a template.
So a Polymer element, it's
creating an element named
my-element, which, when you use
it, is the tag name you use.
And it just has a template.
And the template has
CSS and some HTML.
And this is about as
simple as it can get.
And it justs put out
hello from my element,
and if you inspect
it, it's my own.
And this just works today.
But you can add
a prototype to it
if you want to add
behaviors, if you
want to add properties and
methods to your element.
So, in this case, we added
a method for say hello.
And on a click, it's going
to do alert, howdy folks.
And we're missing
some of the code
here to make it a
little simpler to read.
But I click on it,
it says, howdy folks.
And then data binding is
another big piece that we do.
So in this case,
we have a property
on the protocol called owner
that's default value is Rob.
And then if you use the mustache
syntax actually in the HTML,
and there's no other setup you
have to do, it will just work.
So when it renders, it puts
Rob built me with Polymer.
But you can publish
those properties, too.
So if you want to publish
an API for your element,
you can add it to the
attributes attribute, which
is cleverly named, of course.
In this case, it has a default
value, but when you use it,
you can override that value.
The user of that
element can use that API
to override that value.
And it does when it renders.
But wait, you say,
how do I use this
with x, where x is name a
framework, name a technology,
name some random
thing that you found
on the internet somewhere?
So this is about interop.
So Polymer elements are
"just" custom elements.
This is our story for this.
And I put just in quotes
because custom elements
are really, really cool.
Outside of the
element boundaries,
you have this element.
It's got shadow DOM,
so it's got some scope.
It has a boundary that can be
pierced if you really want,
but it's safe in there.
Outside of that element
boundary, looking in,
they can be interactive with
just like regular DOM elements.
They have properties.
They have methods.
They have events.
This is just useful.
It's just like any
other DOM element.
Once you're inside
that element boundary,
that's where you get
all the Polymer goodies.
And the thing is,
those Polymer goodies
don't leak outside of
that element boundary.
So this lets Polymer play
really nicely with lots and lots
of other kinds of projects
because you can just
drop this element
in and it acts just
like a regular DOM element.
So for interop, it's a
really, really good story.
And you'll have instances where,
if you're inside of an element,
there's things that need
to know about shadow DOM.
But, basically, outside of
the element, it's all good.
You can share
everything you want.
Inside of the element,
you get all the goodies.
But things have to be
a little bit smarter.
So the take away is this is a
really, really big new thing.
We're bootstrapping
this ecosystem.
And it's really for everyone.
We're not going to be the first
do this, or the only people
to do this.
We expect a lot
of other providers
to do this, and
individual developers
to build elements
and share them.
We're creating a technology
for catalogs, standards
for documentation, ways
of distributing elements,
and tooling, like
we were showing you
with the designer tool.
And we're moving kind of
on all of this all at once.
And where we're going, so
Polymer is in alpha right now.
We said we were a pre alpha for
a fairly absurd amount of time.
We changed that about two
months ago now to alpha.
We'll be beta once the native
features ship in one browser.
So what this looks
like is Chrome 36,
which is Canary right now.
It'll be in the stable channel
on the next two months.
And then, kind of
at that point, we'll
flip it to beta because every
time one of the native features
comes in, there's a lot of
churn right at the end, where
it works subtly differently
than the Polyfill does,
and we have to
reconcile the two.
So we want to kind of avoid
exposing people to that churn.
But you'll see, later
on, right after me, right
after the break, that
there's a lot of crazy people
who've actually built
stuff on this already.
And more power to them.
So how can you help?
You don't have to do a
thing because there's
going to be a whole bunch
of people here talking
to you in a minute.
You don't even have to move.
Go to Polymer project.org
and read more.
You can tweet us.
You can say love us there, too.
I'll assume you're
talking about an actor.
You can check us out
on Stack Overflow.
That's where we like
all the questions to go.
There's a Polymer
dev mailing list.
We really prefer the
questions get there
so everyone can see them.
Build us something.
Write an element.
Wrap an API, and share it.
Join the revolution.
And check back soon because
we'll be at Google I/O,
and it'd be awesome to see
you guys all there, too.